okay the next speaker is quentin bertay
from google go ahead quentin
so thanks to the organizers for this
wonderful
yeah
for this wonderful program and workshop
thanks for inviting me and uh yeah so i
like a lot of people i guess i haven't
given a talk live in about two years so
apologies if i'm a bit rusty on top of
the jet lag
uh so today i'm going to talk about the
computational trade-offs um in graph
models so this is essentially work that
was done
before i uh i joined google research
um so i guess i mean one of the one of
the big topics uh of this workshop is uh
how do you reconcile the um
how do you reconcile the algorithmic and
statistical complexities uh of a lot of
different uh problems
and you know why do we care about these
problems well you know it's kind of the
typical motivation slides uh we care
about this because more and more uh we
have data-driven approaches and you know
all uh all of science all of business as
well but you know in our most scientific
fields are trying to exploit very large
data sets and uh very importantly uh
they're trying to do this on data that
already exists right i think so in
statistics there's kind of a paradigm
that you ask yourself a question and
then you know
trying to get data that will or not
invalidate this problem now more and
more you know there's large amounts of
data that exist somewhere you ask
yourself a question and you look at this
particular data set so
it means that most of the data that you
have might not be relevant to the
problem at hand
uh it also means that you know
the model that you know you're going to
look at this uh data with and the data
itself maybe
can have a lot of difficulties so it can
be complex it can have a lot of
heterogeneity it can be more or less
valuable etc
and so you know
it becomes more and more important when
you have these very very very large
data sets to care about the
computational costs
uh in complex models so it's going to be
two reasons for this
the first one is that
the data sets that we have
are increasingly large so this means you
know when you think about it from a very
uh classical statistical point of view
you have
observations uh x1 xn so you have a very
large number of observations and
sometimes it can be also
hard to
access all at the same time
and you have a high dimensional
parameter
so this means that you know
what you're trying to model this data
with would be a probability that have a
parameter that can also uh have a very
very high dimension
so now because of that it means that
in a lot of uh in other situations it's
going to make a lot of sense to impose
additional structure on this parameter
so you know this can be a sparsity this
can be uh some kind of symmetry etc the
idea behind this is that if you're just
trying to solve uh this high dimensional
statistical problem you might not have
enough data and it might not be also
relevant uh with respect to the question
that you're asking so you're gonna need
uh to make some assumption to you know
better fit with the question that you're
asking and also be able to statistically
solve anything
um so one of the ways that you can do
this uh is to solve you know
optimization uh problems so trying to
fit some sort of likelihood that depends
on your data uh
to uh
to uh sorry to find a to fit a parameter
so that your
data fits very well with uh some uh with
this particular value of the of the
parameter or to do a hypothesis testing
so here it's not going to be you know
solving a solving an optimization
problem on a very complex set it's going
to be you know taking averages
over a very very large set
so what we care about here is having you
know
computationally efficient methods for
these very high uh dimensional
statistical problems
okay so
this can seem a bit at odds with you
know
recent advances in uh in the
in the field at large right so
what people call machine learning ai etc
uh that in practice you know you use
first order optimization for you know
anything and it just works right us
theoreticians don't really have uh
guarantees but you know people observe
that uh it does work so i used to have i
used to have uh in this version of the
slide uh
very good empirical results not a lot of
theoretical understanding so i think in
the last few years we've had more and
more theoretical understanding about you
know just
doing uh
gradient based uh updates on the on
these very very large
models on neural networks
uh
now we have uh we have some more and
more
but i think one of the issues of you
know these results in non-convex uh
optimization for statistical learning
are that you know people think that all
learning problems right meaning all uh
average case uh optimization uh
problems on
reasonable instances whatever this means
uh aren't computationally easy and you
know i think this uh intuition is a is
wrong in general and i think uh so a
mathematic a mathematical analysis of
these problems uh reveals uh
you know requires a final understanding
of what's going on
and actually i'm into a link i'm going
to come back to this a bit later but uh
there has been recent work on you know
trying to uh
classify uh instances of random graphs
with or without uh a click uh with these
very large neural networks and they
observe the same kind of transitions as
uh what uh as what we already have so
the kind of transitions i'm going to uh
to talk about so i think you know this
this says that you know these things are
are very good uh but they're definitely
not magic
so the framework that we're gonna look
at to make you know things easy in
general it's going to be detection or
estimation of some you know
structured signal uh so this can be
sparsity etc that has a certain level of
intensity so here it should be of
intensity theta
um so this can mean that this means that
we're going to try to distinguish
so you know plenty click i'm going to
come back to this will be an example of
this
uh an example where we have a situation
where we have an absence of signal so
some high dimensional distribution p0
that you can think of as a pure noise
right so examples include you know
standard gaussian
or
a random graph where all the edges of
probability one half independently so
another training graph
to a structured signal right so there's
some parameters some vector v
uh such that we have some distribution
which is you know
pure noise
plus feet of v whatever you know this
theta v will mean so sometimes it can be
you know
you're adding fitter v uh to the um
to the mean uh for some you know case
parts v uh it can be also you know
adding it to the covariance matrix or
adding it to the expectation of
probabilities
so this would be the case of
the planetary partner
so this has been you know thinking of
these problems like this has been an
active line of research
in all of statistics really and
initially it was quite removed from
algorithmic concerns was looking at
another type of uh statistic of
complexity a statistical complexity
that's also related to you know
how large these sets are uh etc and
really based on you know trying to
understand from an information theoretic
point of view the complexity of these
problems related to the structure of the
underlying parameter
and often it's formulated as a
hypothesis testing problem
based on you know independence
x1 to xn
uh
and so here yeah so uh a test that will
you know distinguish uh zero one uh
these two distributions has a measure
that's performed that measure as a sorry
performance that's measured by the
probability of error right so
the probability of saying the wrong
thing on the one this under one
distribution and the probability of
saying the wrong thing under uh all the
others so you can
think of this either as the maximum
probability or the average probability
uh under under the signal
and so
you're really looking for functions that
behave
very differently
under
these two types of distributions
and now you know the question becomes uh
when do such functions exist
uh and when do functions of a certain
class exist right so in particular
functions that are easily computation
that can be easily computed
and so
this will be you know if you don't care
about
if you formulate it
really from just a
classical statistics point of view it's
just going to be you know some notion of
statistical distance uh between these
distributions right so it can be
completely again removed from any sort
of uh computational
complexity it can just mean you know
total variation distance
between these
but as we'll see it can also incorporate
a lot of these algorithmic concepts
questions so far
um
so you know
now statistics in general tells you you
know you should
there's one really good way uh to look
at uh to look at these problems uh which
is to solve you know some optimization
problems of these likelihood ratios of
these likelihood functions
uh and so now you know of course the
first roadblock is what happens
if the likelihood method is empty harm
right so this is something that happens
in sparse linear regression or
stochastic block model uh so
do you try to follow you know the
usual recipe coming from classical
statistics and it leads to an np-hard
problem right so that's
it's not really great uh however i would
argue that you know the the worst case
hardness uh in this case gives you kind
of a zero of order uh information about
the true statistical complexity of this
problem under some sort of computational
uh assumption so there are algorithms
that exist for frequent instances of
np-hard problem so clustering on convex
regression alternating minimization etc
or sometimes also
proxy functionals and optimization
problem so this means you know you
you don't try to find something that
often solves the empty hard problem you
just solve you just change completely uh
the problem in another one so that you
know it will still have a nice
statistical properties
and so in order to be able to say that
you know anything is hard here we're
going to need to be able to say that
some task is hard to achieve
consistently and efficiently
and so i think i mean really maybe this
is because i approached problems like
that uh this is really best captured by
looking at this
from you know a statistical point of
view saying you know under some
distribution your
so a whole class of function will behave
this way and under another distribution
another way
so this is really what we uh what we
think about when we say you know we're
thinking about hardness of a statistical
problem
uh we're saying that you know
if you have a function that takes values
uh in zero one right saying so it's this
type of distribution or this type of
distribution based on the data
it will have it will say the same thing
with very high probability
measured by epsilon here
for all tests under these two
distributions right so this is in some
sense the you know type of a
worst case for statisticians it's you
know you're trying to distinguish two
distributions but you already know from
all these tools in information theory
that this is going to be impossible with
the amount of data that you have
um
and so now if you think of this uh
from the point of view of you know
trying to mix statistics and uh
complexity theory
what you'd like is a situation where
there exists a test that behaves
very differently uh under these two
distributions right so that you know
you have uh psi uh it will say that the
that psi is equal to zero and the po of
probability close to one and
uh under probably under p1 with
probability close to zero
but
if we're only looking at you know
tractable tractable tests so you know
whatever definition you give to
tractable
it will have
probability a difference in probability
uh very close to zero
so that's the kind of idea of you know
statistical difficulty for tractable
methods you're looking for you're
looking for this type of situation right
so a situation where a statistical
problem is technically
uh statistically doable but
this seems to be hub uh
for tractable methods and again kind of
you know suggest that there is a
fundamental difference between uh
between
functions that are easily computable and
functions that are not
looked at from the length of
you know behavior under certain
probabilities
okay so this is the
uh i think a mandatory slide for this
workshop so the planted clique problem
which is kind of the
golden problem uh for these types of
questions
uh so the the plenty click assumption
says that if you're looking at a an
erdogany random graph if you know
all edges independent with probability
one-half
and you modify this distribution by you
know adding a click of size okay
then it's hard to distinguish
these two distributions based on one
input
of the graph
if the size of the clique
is a power strictly smaller than
one-half
[Music]
compared to the size of the graph right
so well the end to the one-half regime
there are algorithms for that and
otherwise
uh it's believed
that this is impossible
so there's a wide range of evidence uh
for this assumption so you know sam
talked about uh some of some of squares
methods but there's been other types of
uh you know restricted algorithm so
looking at statistical queries etc
looking at
uh also you know proving hardness of
other things
uh using plantar clique and that seems
uh consistent so far
and so the consequence one of the
consequences of this assumption is that
this has been used for reduction uh
based on this problem to establish
hardness of other statistical problems
right so i think a guy had a
presentation yesterday with a
very complete slide with a lot of uh
with a lot of these pollen so we for uh
new to that
and you know already i think we're kind
of uh we're kind of uh
lucky in some sense because uh plenty
click is i think a problem that you can
more or less sell to statisticians or
people who care a little bit about
applications right you can talk about
networks communities finding you know
densely connected uh
uh
number of uh
of agents in a graph so it's not
something that looks you know completely
opaque like some satisfiability problem
but still i think you know it's
it's also it's also very nice that it
can be easily connected to a lot of
other problems that make a lot of sense
uh
in uh in the statistical community so
i'm gonna talk about one of these uh one
of these problems today
be a kind of a
variant of a graph model uh but there
will be a supervised in nature meaning
they will have some side information
before i go uh in this problem do you
have any questions about
presenting it for the third time in a
week makes it
makes it easier
okay so this is a work with nikolai
berlin who is my phd student at
cambridge
and it's about statistical and
computational rates and you know problem
they can either call link prediction or
graph
uh logistic regression
so uh what is this problem so
uh in general so as i said you know
you can see the problem of 90 click on
many other problems
uh
as a statistical problems are on grass
where there's a link between the
presence of an edge ij
and the properties of vertices i and j
right so
the stochastic block model is such an
example so we have
two communities so you know you belong
to community one or two
and the probability that you are
connected with an edge depends only on
the on these two things right so if
i and j belong to the same community
means you have a certain probability
otherwise not etcetera
and then you get a graph g that's
generated by this model
and you're trying to say something about
you know this function but the link
between
ij and
these
vertices ioj are finding you know the
properties themselves of the vertices
range
um an approach that's been a bit
different where you know you don't
consider the
the graph as data but more as uh side
information
there's total variation denoising but i
mean there's been also kind of other
points of views on this but
what in general this means is that
you'll have
noisy observations of you know some data
for every vertex
and
there is an assumption that this data is
in some sense smooth on the graph right
so that if
two things f2 nodes are connected then
these values should not be too far from
each other right so you can think of you
know a lot of sensors that are somewhere
in a room they're connected if they're
not too far and so if the underlying
signal that they're trying to measure
is indeed smooth then you'd think that
the
smoothness is preserved
on this graph
uh and so there's been uh there's been a
work on on this as well but here again
you know it's a so it is a supervised
problem but you're you're seeing uh
the graph as a structure
rather than as the data itself
so what we were interested in
was a problem where you have side
information and you see the graph as
being generated by a random model
so here the data is as follows so you
have
covariates
i for every node
in the network
so you can think of this as you know you
have a
you have a you have a network of
different uh of different elements and
uh
for each of these elements you have a
very very long uh
for every uh yeah sorry node in the
graph you have a very very long vector
of information so this can be you know
information about a user in a
in a network uh
and it's considered deterministic so you
know
measure these for everyone and you kind
of uh you have a you have them somewhere
and then you have also the partial
observation of uh the graph so this
means that you'll have uh binary
variable for every ij
uh
for a subset
of these uh
of these pairs of size and you'll have
observed the presence or absence
of an edge right so this means you
it means you have a
you have a graph like this you don't
observe you don't query the graph
everywhere but in some places
you'll have quite it and in some places
you will observe no edge and in some
places you'll observe one right
right so how are the covariates related
uh to the presence or absence of an edge
so through this uh link function
so the probability that uh y i j will be
one so the probability that there will
be indeed
an edge for this random for this
observation
uh will depend on the score so it will
depend on you know x i and xj these two
uh vectors of covariates
through an unknown matrix right so
there'll be uh maybe some score some
affinity score we'll call it uh between
i and j that will depend on this uh
unknown matrix
uh and then independently uh
these edges will be present on or not
with some probability right so if this
affinity score is very high this means
that there's a probability very close to
one
that the edges are connected and
otherwise if the score is very much
in high negative numbers low negative
numbers
um then the probability is very
procedure right so here you could have
it won't change much in the problem as
if you have you know any sort of a
function that goes smoothly from zero to
one uh yeah
right and so
here what are we trying to do we're
trying to estimate
theta star uh under some assumptions on
theta star so i'll explain a little bit
where we we think there should be blocks
pass
low range
and one of the challenges that we have
is we can be in a high dimensional
problem so
here this matrix is of size d square and
it takes two vectors of size d and
creates a scalar out of them so it's
subsidized d squared and we can have
much less sometimes than d square
observations right so we're introducing
this combinatorial constraint so that
you know even under this low sampling
regime we are still well conditioned but
then this means that the problem will be
computationally hard i mean
it will yield naturally some
computational uh hardness
and so
the motivation that we have
for this generating model
uh is so i said that you know we have
some sort of affinity right so we we
were saying that when uh
when ing will have a very high score the
probability will be very close to one
what does this mean when we when you
write theta star in a spectral
decomposition right so it's low rank we
assume that
uh it will be so this quadratic form
will be written as a
small sum uh between 1 and r
of these lambda l and then scalar
product of ul
on x ion and on xj
so the lower rank assumption says that
uh
there's very few of these vectors right
so the affinity depends on this kind of
products weighted by these eigenvalues
so there's very few of these vectors it
is indeed actually uh orange so if i
find the pen that works slightly better
so we're going to have u1
like this and so
what this says is that if we have uh if
we have all our elements it
if we have all our vectors that can be
projected and this you know low
dimensional space the
actual affinity depends indeed only on
uh this low dimensional representation
um and also so this is an additional
assumption that we make that it depends
really indeed only on the few relevant
coefficients of x i actually right so
the whole data about each of these user
was measured
before we really knew that we were gonna
you know
try to determine uh presence or absence
of an edge so if these two people were
connected in the graph and so it means
that there might be a lot of information
that you know is not related at all to
our problems
when you're writing
so right when you're you're gonna write
uh your sum of so
you look at it uh like this right your
sum of x i and xj
uh at in this is st and then you know
weighted by all these things block
sparsity means really there's uh
not necessarily to contiguous subset uh
here i'm doing it in a contiguous way
right but subset of uh
elements
in x i and xj
that are relevant
uh
and those are the only ones we care
about like so if otherwise if you have
you know if you start having
just any sort of uh sparsity pattern uh
like this
it means well you know
the thief feature of uh user j is
related to the s feature of user i
and somehow this is a bit you know
harder to motivate right here we're just
saying you know there's a subset of
useful features for this particular
network and that's it
one thing that's interesting is that it
goes a little bit beyond
geometric uh description right so it's
possible to have negative eigenvalues
otherwise it just means that you have a
you have a metric problem uh here we can
be in a situation where you know if
i'm not gonna mess this up live but you
know if we have
lambda one
uh if we have lambda one that's positive
this means that you know
things that are close in this dimension
will be uh will be connected
uh and if we have uh
if you if we have
uh lambda2
that's negative it means that things
that are
uh very different
under uh this dimension will be
connected as well right so this means
that you know
something here and something here
might actually have a higher probability
of being connected
than you know
these two right so the reason we're
motivating this is you know we're saying
it's not only going to be uh
similar things that are going to be uh
attract that are going to be naturally
connected uh in this network but it can
also be you know dc mr dissimilarity in
some dimension so this can be you know
trying to have users that are
geographically in a similar situation
but you know one of them is trying to
buy and the other one is trying to sell
or you know any sort of anti-symmetric
uh thing that could be related to
affinity in a social network
uh
however you know if we on the other hand
if we make the assumption that uh
the parameters uh that the matrix that
we have in the middle is semi-definitely
positive then it becomes indeed the same
thing as uh metric learning
right so here there is a situation where
we have
an object each with some representation
in a low dimensional space
we have some queries of similarities so
right we've shown people you know is
this image like this one
uh it depends on you know how close they
are
in some mental space maybe uh for some
people so how these uh how close these
representations are
and this is recovered by this model in
the special case where you know our
matrix is semi-definitely positive and
has some
rank r
there's also so in non-parametric
statistics
uh some work on this on you know trying
to have a non-parametric link function
between x i actually and
the probability of being connected
okay so uh
here this can be seen as a generalized
linear model
when we rewrite this affinity function
we can rewrite it in a way that you know
this says that it's going to be the same
thing
as the multiplication of some very large
design matrix
and uh the vectorized so version of uh
of the parameter matrix that we're
looking for
uh
and so this means that indeed we are in
just a
no very large so d square
logistic regression problem
with capital n observation that are
indexed by the ij that are here
now you know you can try and explore
this problem like this the only issue is
that the structural assumption that
we've made right so this is actually uh
why this matters the fact that we're we
have block sparsity and we have low rank
this is something that's a bit harder to
translate
uh into you know conditions on the on
this vector
and on the other hand you can think of
this as a logistic version of uh
trace regression models right so there's
been
models in
models in
in statistics
uh where some uh
matrices are observed through the
scanner product with another matrices
so some references and here this is a
special case of this where again you
know these are
these matrices that we take scalar
products with have a this special
structure of xjxir transpose
and then this you know
this will form the design matrix that we
have here
so some assumptions some additional
assumptions that we make in this model
so
this is you know necessary because the
problem is
imposed
in general
and so we need some additional
structural assumptions so here this will
be
block sparsity and rank
the first one is that the probabilities
are bounded away from zero and one
so this is classical in
estimation and this is actually
necessary
so the issue is that
if the
if
if the affinity scores can become
extremely high or extremely low
then you know it's hard to distinguish
uh between an affinity score of you know
1 billion and 10 billion
uh and so you're going to have because
they you know they create uh they create
probabilities that are either you know
extremely close to one or extremely
extremely
and so by
letting these affinity scores go through
this logistic model you've destroyed a
lot of information uh very close to zero
or very close to one and so this is why
it's necessary to make uh this sort of
assumption they can you know uh
be used they can be translated into an
assumption on cheetahstar and xih
uh it's required uh for identifiability
in some sense
um and an additional assumption is
required so this is an assumption on the
covariates which is a bit like the
restricted isometry assumption in the
sparse linear regression so i'm not
going to go
too much in the details of this but
essentially it's saying that you know
when you
when you uh when you take a product of a
s block sparse matrix or like the one
that we have
um
of these vectors of these covariates so
covariates
times blocks parts matrix times uh
covalent again which is what we're
what we're using in this uh in this
problem then you haven't modified a lot
the norm of this matrix right so this
means that essentially
the covariates acting on s block sparse
matrices
uh are well conditioned
they don't create a very degenerate uh
situations
uh so this is a this is equivalent to uh
some sort of uh restricted isometric
property
on uh the design matrix that we have uh
restricted to vector forms of s blocks
past matrices so there's been some work
on this generalization
of these conditions and you know it
looks very weird like this
but it's satisfied with high probability
under various randomness models so i
know i said in the beginning that we're
assuming that the
x i x j and set omega are deterministic
uh but you know this means that
if they are deterministic from your
point of view but have been gathered
through a sort of
stochastic sampling process before
that's completely independent of the
rest of your observations then you're in
the clear
so
in this model so if we if we look at the
log likelihood that we're going to uh
try and
uh maximize
then you know this is a very classical
what we have is that
the observed function can be written as
a population version right so sort of
expectation version of this function
plus a linear term
and this population version
itself is maximized at the true value of
the parameter and then the difference
between uh the value at theta and the
value at a star depends on the
feedback label divergence so you know
difference in probabilities of observing
uh
of observing uh these uh of having these
observations under these two models
uh and so now this really kind of guides
the type of the type of uh analysis that
we should make
uh of this model if we want to say
something about you know
what will maximize
this
this term
well there are two things that we must
say first we should understand
how uh
this behaves around the tester right the
local geometry of the of the of this
function
close to fita star so it's going to be
related to the
difference in probabilities of observing
observing uh
uh this data under the two parameters
and we're gonna need to control the
deviation term so this is just the
noise in your observations that you have
uh
that you have
coming from your generative model right
then so this is going to be easy to do
here we're going to have
a sum of iid sub gaussian variables and
so
uh we're going to be able to uh to
maximize well the difference between
uniformly between the population and uh
and uh data version of these functions
right so you know skipping a lot of the
details
what this leads to is that under uh
so under the assumptions that i
presented
on the covariate x and on the parameter
function on the parameter matrix fitted
star
for combinatorial mle so essentially
saying you know something that maximizes
the likelihood
among all block sparse laurent matrices
we have
control how far the estimator is from
the true value and some know
and we control this in a manner that you
know kind of separates well the
statistical complexities of the
different problems here
so the first one so
k r over n
this is the
this is the difficulty of estimating
a k by k symmetric symmetric matrix of
rank r right so you have
two times uh kr
coefficients and you have n observations
so this is
essentially in terms of square
the complexity
and
then the complexity of finding the
support of k among d variables this is
essentially a
log of d choose of characters d
divided by n
so there is we have matching lower bound
of up to constants
but you know the two estimators that we
consider here so one is penalized one is
constraints these constrained they are
not computationally tractable
so now again you know we're back
to a general question can we
in this supervised model
have both can we get
optimal statistical rates
and a polynomial time estimator
so the first thing that can be tried is
to relax
the block sparsity uh penalty in a you
know l1 uh manner
and actually when you do this one thing
that you realize is that uh it doesn't
you know if you relax it in the l1 norm
then it doesn't matter that it is block
sparse you would have you know if you if
you permute all of these coefficients
around you will have the same l1 norm
and you wouldn't have at all the same
you know
block sparse l01
so this means that you've made the
problem you know much easier in some
sense because i mean
much easier from a
from a computational point of view but
much harder from a statistical point of
view because you've made the space of
possible fita star much much higher
so we can show that you know indeed
under some assumptions under the same
assumptions we're going to have
um some you know nice ish
statistical complexity uh for this
estimator
but it is suboptimal right so because it
it corresponds to a harder statistical
problem which is
you know
finding the best case k square uh sparse
matrix
so we are just like in a lot of these
other statistical problems in
in this situation
so we have uh rates of estimation
so this is the opt statistical optimal
so minimax
uh rate uh for this problem uh the
methods that you know methods that work
here
are uh computationally hard
we have
lasso type method so you know l1
regularized method uh for this problem
that works but you know require uh but
that gets you level of errors uh then
have that out of a much older uh
uh a much higher order
uh and
well we'd like to know something about
what happens in the middle
uh right if we have a fixed constant
rate rank right it's one two three we
have in some sense we gap from k to k
square here
uh that is observed
and so you know the
the way to do this uh in general so you
know philosophically
is that you're going to say well i have
this assumption uh that the plant
eclipse problem is very hard
so i'm going to
hypothesize for a second that i can have
a much better algorithm
for
problem at hand that i have
and i'm going to try and transform
instances of the plaintiff pollen into
instances of the problem with complexity
i'm trying to determine and see from
this i can get to a contradiction
and so
this is what we do here we were saying
you know we want to have
a collection of uh parameter matrices
uh such that for you know given
covariates that we care about
we will have the
matrix of probability so you know
matrix of sigma x transpose theta 0x
uh be
one half
everywhere
right so this will be for theta zero
which is equal to zero
right so here this will this this would
be true for for any x
and
at the same time so if
instead we have theta s then the matrix
of probabilities corresponds
uh to the matrix of probabilities in a
erdos strange
graph we have a plan to keep right so we
have
time to click of size k
here this means that you know
here we're going to have probability q
and here we're going to have probability
one half every once right so i said
perfectly but it's really you know
planted a denser subgraph
and so it is possible to do this so we
can construct by by hand so you know
again here and waving a little bit the
details but we can construct by hand uh
vectors x i uh that have uh this pro
that have this property
and uh
to take matrices
uh fitter s
uh that have this property as well but
such that theta s and theta zero
are at the type of distance under which
it doesn't seem to be able to you know
distinguish from a computational uh from
a computational point of view
and so
what we have now is that you know
we have so our matrix theta zero so
that's
zero
here we have all the possible
matrices theta s
that lead
to matrices of probabilities
like this
and the distance here
between
the parameter matrices
uh will be alpha times k square n where
alpha is just you know another
parametrization of uh of q
because it's a constant if alpha is very
large then q is very large
so
if there is an estimator now
that you know is computable in
polynomial time
uh and for which
we can have
something of
something of this form right so
something either you know
much lower order uh then then k square
or have you know
uh very small constants and no
logarithmic term here
then what we can do is we can run this
estimator on the known x so right we
construct our x's ourself and we take y
to be you know all these binary
variables to be the adjacency matrix of
the graph
we plug all this into our
into our
into uh oh you know magical uh estimator
for theta hat
and from this we can solve uh the
plaintiff column right so this would
naturally lead to a contradiction uh
on this uh on this assumption
right so
here you know uh
the thing that's interesting is that the
you know the x that we have construct
are a bit uh
[Music]
bit weird in some sense right that don't
they they don't seem to uh they don't
seem to be you know these very dense
factors etc they would really expect in
this sort of problem uh and so one one
natural question would be you know if
now
you know the x's are fixed if someone is
asking you know can i solve this problem
for this particular
set of features then do i get uh do i
get uh this type of contradiction again
and i guess i mean so um yeah
closer uh
very close to 45 minutes so closer to uh
to this uh
i think uh if i only do half then to an
hour if i do one of the slides that i
plan so i think i'm
gonna stop around here
um so the contributions that we have
here so we have a
supervised model of on on graph so this
is really you know what we found was uh
was interesting to have something where
you can say
well you can see a little bit about the
statistical versus computational
complexity of this problem uh with side
information which is
something that uh typically is not very
present
for this type of problem it's always
more of a
unsupervised nature so you just have you
know
one random graph and no other no
oversight data
suboptimal performance for a lasso type
estimator so this is not something
that's uh present
uh in you know typical sparse linear
regression uh problems
and a computational lower bound uh in a
regression problem so now they said you
know one uh open question would be
this sort of general reduction scheme
that works for any covariate design
and you know from
from
the point of view of looking at a wider
set of columns so if you have more
general link functions or if you have
you know
another type of non-convex optimization
uh problem on uh on matrices do you
still get uh the same type of
of uh statistical computational
trade-offs
no i'll stop here thanks a lot
[Applause]
questions
is there is there enough you said that
you don't get like very um
you know sort of vectors that look nice
or something like that out of is is
there a natural distribution that you
would want if you if you wanted if you
wanted to
um
vectors that looked nicer that came from
some some distribution is there a
natural distribution to think of that
you would try to target for the
reduction
i think so something that would look a
bit more uniform here so we're getting
essentially you know one hot vectors
yeah uh in the goviad so
if if it were possible to say you know
uh
guess something like you know uh
uh well
i mean you know i know i said they were
deterministic but you know uh something
uh that would be satisfied as well by
you know something coming from a high
dimensional random plus minus one uh
vector i think this would be uh more
this would be more interesting so you
know let's say for all
for all design matrices x
uh
that you know are in this class
where uh
vectors with random plus minus one are
uh
with high probability this would be
interesting uh but this is yeah this
isn't something we've been able to kind
of link uh so far
so i think it just uh just makes the uh
makes the connection between plenty
click and the type of distribution that
you're trying to get very complicated so
trying to
[Music]
invert a sparse
[Music]
response linear
observation and so yeah i think this is
why
operation so this is why i think it's a
little bit complicated because
essentially you have you have to solve a
hard problem to kind of design a
reduction
so yeah this has been kind of the uh the
complexity so far but yeah something i'd
be interested in
seeing if it's possible to do
thanks
people may be maybe eager for lunch
for the questions
okay let's thank point one more time
i think we're back at 2 30.
i'll double check that